figaro live bonsoir bienvenue 19h04 nous
sommes en direct bienvenue à la maison
merci de passer la soirée avec nous
entre amis finalement parce que l'un
d'entre nous l'un de notre bande est de
retour de voyage vous savez ces sept
acolytes un peu baroudeur toujours par
monts et par vaux à il en a vu à travers
ses périples c'est le copain qui est
grand reporter au figaro magazine celui
qui nous fait un peu rêver quand il nous
montre ses photos en rentrant bonsoir
vincent joly bonsoir thibault ça vous va
comme présentation vous est ce que vous
êtes l'ami qui vexe ses copains parce
qu'il rentre avec soulagement non
général de jeu je sais que c'est
tellement embêtant quand on a un oncle
ou un cousin qui rentrent de voyage en
thaïlande et qui veut absolument nous
montrer ses 350 photos j'avais justement
de jeu les distille avec soin genre
c'est un peu sur instagram et puis donc
là vous venez le faire en public s'il
est bien voilà on l'a où on ne l'a
demandé bon est ce que vous allez nous
faire rêver ce soir on espère bah ça va
être assez facile vu le sujet quand même
bon évidemment alors quand même déjà
mettez vous à l'aise s'il vous plaît
regardez ce que je vous ai amené parce
que quand même soirée soirée ensemble
tenez voilà les chaussons vous mettez
bien aussi j'ai les miens on est dans
notre salon on est ensemble voilà on
enlève les chaussures vous je vous
laisse prendre votre temps comme ça on
est tout à fait à l'aise problème on est
parfait tout cela on se mélange
formidable et on est on est vraiment
nécessaire oui mais vous allez voir que
vous allez être confortable c'est bien
mieux et ça vous sentez bon on y va vous
réagissez évidemment sur lefigaro.fr
surtout sur youtube et on prend toutes
toutes vos questions je les transmets
est comme ça on peut on peut en discuter
bon vincent
on va voir tant de tous développés mais
vous êtes partis ou en fait très
brièvement raconté nous alors très
brièvement masse est simple donc on est
moi je suis donc vous l'avez dit le
reporter au figaro magazine et j'ai
proposé de faire un sujet sur les îles
australes françaises alors les îles
australes françaises qu'est ce que c'est
la plupart des français ignorent même
leur existence et alors qu'on volé leur
demande de les situer sur une carte
la personne les trouve certes elles sont
petites mais c'est surtout parce que
vraiment beaucoup de gens ne savent pas
qu'elles existent c'est aussi un peu
normal vu que cd ils sont officiellement
pas habiter où on avant de partir sur la
sur la première photo ce que ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on regarde où
c'est peut-être bien finalement alors
ben voilà regarder cette cette carte
j'ai mis un petit point rouge enfin
google maps a mis un petit point rouge
sur les îles kerguelen
expliquez moi comment on fait pour aller
là bas et puis après on va on va on va
développer et ben comment on fait pour
aller là bas bah vous le voyez c'est
quand même très loin c'est au milieu de
l'océan c'est vraiment au milieu de
l'océan c'est dans une zone qu'on
appelle une zone de convergence des des
fronts donc on n'est pas encore tout à
fait en antarctique on est vraiment au
sud de l'océan indien c'est ce qu'on
appelle la zone sub antarctique et
cardio l'aisne se trouve à une droite il
ya c'est intéressant je sais à la
frontière entre ce que les marins
appellent les quarantièmes rugissants et
les cinq centièmes ça me plaît
je suis très bon oui oui et comment on y
va et on le voit c'est tellement loin tu
évidemment hélicoptère impossible
d'accord il ya un bienvenue attendu
aussi impossible il ya jamais eu il ya
eu un projet de piste d'atterrissage à
kerguelen d'accord ne s'est jamais fait
et l'avion pour le reste des australes
ce serait complètement impossible aussi
donc on y va en bateau et meriva à bord
du marion dufresne c'est un navire
océanographique et ben alors justement
on regarde cette cette première photo si
vous le si vous le voulez bien le marion
dufresne
voici regarder c'est ce bateau alors
parlez moi de ce bateau parce que c'est
votre compagnon de route ou c'est vous
le compagnon de route du marion dufresne
ouais alors en fait le marion dufresne
c'est vraiment un rêve pour les
passionnés de marennes et pour les
passionnés de science et pour les
scientifiques c'est vraiment un navire
mythique déjà par sa construction c'est
un navire océanographique qui est très
très long sans remettre donc c'est une
belle bête et il est fait en fait pour
affronter les mers difficiles dans
lesquelles il doit s'aventurer il a été
alors ça en fait c'est le marion
dufresne 2 en fait y en a eu un avant
celui là si je me trompe pas il a été
mis à l'eau en 1995 dont il est déjà il
est il est donc on va dire dans son
milieu fin de vie a été rénové plusieurs
fois et c'est effectivement un navire
qui fait rêver parce que c'est le cordon
ombilical qui va permettre à la france
de maintenir à la fois sa souveraineté
sur les îles australes mais aussi de
desservir de déposer bas les
scientifiques les militaires et les
travailleurs qui doivent se
finalement oui parce que pour assurer la
présence pour ce martyr on ne peut pas
partir comme ça il faut partir un très
long moment si j'ai bien compris alors
oui il ya les îles australes encore une
fois on peut pas y aller quand on veut
très loin voilà c'est ça donc on y va
quatre fois par an quatre fois par an le
marion dufresne il part de la réunion il
va d'abord rejoindre l'archipel creusait
ensuite l'archipel kerguelen ensuite il
passe voir saint paul qui est une île où
on n'a pas le droit de poser tous
voulaient qu'on regarde la carte à
nouveau si vous trouvez des alors oui
c'est lui c'est pas si facile alors de
la première donc on part de la réunion
la réunion à une demi heure mais oui
c'est facile voilà c'est ici un c'est
bien ça on remonte sur une toute petite
île alors si vous avez là c'est un peu
c'était un peu de ces pioneer
effectivement est-ce qu'il faut alors
c'est assez compliqué mais je vais
essayer de faire simple oui les terres
australes et antarctiques françaises les
taf on t a j'ai vu qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'acronymes un pas facile c'est
pas facile mais c'est un monde compliqué
les taf mais alors les taf c'est les
terres australes et antarctiques
françaises qui sont composés de trois
choses il ya la terre adélie qui est une
bande de terre en antarctique qui est re
a indiqué par la faim tirs revendiqués
par la france qui est plus ou moins
française et la base dumont d'urville et
et voilà donc ont atteint plus tôt avec
l'astrolabe au sud de l'australie il ya
les îles australes c'est celle qui nous
intéresse ce soir et c'est celle où on
s'est rendu pour le figaro donc là les
îles australes c'est l'archipel de
crozet l'archipel kerguelen saint paul
et amsterdam et il ya les îles éparses
et alors les éparses et d'autres îles
qui sont autour de madagascar et qui
alors là sont vraiment des confettis et
donc notamment celle ci île tromelin
micro meneur et bien ça alors vous
m'avez dit combien de deux mètres carrés
moins d'un kilomètre carré arrière de
même un petit et je dézoomer jeu
dézoomer jeu des zooms et voilà donc
vous avez commencé par ceux-ci
brièvement voilà c'est bien ça alors on
part donc sur ce marion dufresne ya même
un hélicoptère alors on est obligé parce
que en fait c'est un peu le paradoxe
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut aller dans
les australes comme en bateau mais par
contre pour la logistique et le
transport des personnes les hip hop
terre est le moyen déjà un le plus
rapide d'accords et le plus efficace
tout bêtement alors hélicoptère et puis
donc vous arrivez dans cette danse est
petit il sait ce alors vous êtes
descendus sur tromelin ou pas on a on a
fait ce que beaucoup de gens un rêve de
faire on a dormi à tromelin à et alors
là vous pouvez pas vous enfuir si un
problème dont on peut pas s'enfuir et
d'ailleurs c'est assez drôle que vous
mentionnez ça parce que tromelin a une
histoire un peu triste a dit l'idée
c'est pas pleurer nos téléspectateurs
s'il vous plaît non mais ces deux
internationaux que vous pouvez lire sur
lefigaro.fr oui évidemment vous
retrouver ses reportages soleil celui
l'âge de sel vous l'avez pas si on ne
s'était pas long à préparation non il ya
eu des esclaves oubliés sur tromelin
d'accord et c'est les oubliés de
tromelin il ya eu un très beau livre
d'ailleurs de irène frain irène frain
qui s'appelle les oubliés de tromelin et
donc il ya eu un naufrage sur cette île
et les comment le capitaine a réussi à
faire un vaisseau de fortune à
s'échapper de tromelin et a promené aux
esclaves qu'ils laissaient sur tromelin
tiendrait et simplement ils sont venus
mais vingt ans plus tard dans quinze ans
plus tard il s'en est bien suivre à
s'assurer on ira lire ça sur le sur le
figaro cette photo elle est là c'est une
photo de troubles c'est là c'est la
petite escale à tromelin avant ça durera
combien de temps cette escaré tromelin
droite 4 juin la réunion ou trois quatre
jours à trois mains et puis donc ensuite
on retourne sur le sur le marion
dufresne c'est bien ça ouais or et qui
sont ces gens là on est où alors là on
est déjà à carde il
est allé un peu vite peut-être qu'on
reviendra et on va on va revenir avec ce
fameux marion dufresne on verra des
photos comme celle ci tout au long de ce
de ce live alors ça on est sur le bateau
la nuit sur le bateau c'est tout à fait
étonnant
ben ça fait partie un peu de l' aventure
à jerez et là c'est un peu le pas ce que
vous partez cinq semaines si j'ai bien
compris combien de temps vous passez sur
le bateau combien de temps à terre à peu
près moitié moitié on va dire que en
tout le la rotation ce qu'on appelle une
opé donc loupé du marion dufresne dans
la 4 par an c'est pratiquement 8000 km à
bas à faire en bateau et en forme de
losange dont font part de la réunion
prose est kerguelen amsterdam saint paul
la reine on a fait un losange de l'umih
km en gros on est on va dire quinze
jours sur le bateau afin moitié-moitié
mode simod c'est sur le bateau est donc
là par exemple
on est sur le bateau l'annoncé sur le
bateau c'était c'était un exercice de
sécurité incendie sécurité incendie donc
à une vraie vie sur ce bateau avec cet
hélicoptère vous le prenez souvent que
pour aller à terre il y avait 48 tout le
temps on s'est vraiment obligatoire en
fait le marion dufresne mouiller
au large des côtes des australes et en
fait
l'hélicoptère est là pour
transporter les personnes mais aussi
tout le matériel qui doit être d'accord
il n'est d'accord sur wii parce que et
on va en parler de cette vie sur place
parce que ça c'est très étonnant
j'imagine que c'est pas simple d'habiter
là bas s'il ya des gens qui habitent
vraiment à l'année non alors alors il ya
des gens qui passent un nom sur les
australes mais il n'ya pas d'habitants
il n'y a pas de d'habitants permanents
sur les îles australes en fait on part
notamment pour des missions qui sont au
maximum de 13 mois normalement
et est en général on n'y revient pas il
ya des scientifiques qui peuvent
notamment les scientifiques de
l'institut polaire français paul emile
victor des scientifiques dirige des
programmes scientifiques sont amenés à
revenir de manière ponctuelle sur les
sur les différentes îles jours voilà
surveiller l'état des travaux et des
recherches qui sont effectués dont
parlait vcc les volontaires les
volontaires
vcl retrouver oui mais j'ai vu il ya
vous avez un sacré paquet de date parce
qu'alors je vous propose évidemment de
regarder c'est ce cet article c'était
dans évidemment dans le figaro magazine
d'il ya une semaine ces [ __ ] de
semaine c'est ça alors c'est plus un
tracé un peu plus celui là le 3 juin
2022 on est de combien on est seize
c'est ça c'est ça alors parlez vous
pouvez aussi le retrouver parce que on
l'a également sur sur le le site vous
avez toute une panoplie de reportage je
vais vous les montrer les voici regardez
vous avez des photos magnifiques essais
ces photos qu'on voit qu'on va voir
ensemble alors faute au soir le
précisent qu'ils n'ont pas été prises
par mois à tout parce que dans celles
qu'on va voir il y en a certaines qui
sont de mon m'a demandé d'envoyer mes
photos personnelles mais hexagonaux a
fait je suis parti s'appelle mélanie
wenger
romain c'est grâce à elle qu'on peut
faire cela et ce soir exactement bon on
enchaîne et on continue à regarder ses
photos ensemble avec donc ici on est sur
les îles crozet un archipel kroes alors
racontez moi qu'est ce que vous faites
je vous ai envoyé cette photo pour pour
vous montrer donc là en fait juste on
met des raquettes pour préserver la lave
et j'étais d'accord parce que donc les
îles australes si vous avez très belles
bottes des très belles bottes et des
très belles raquette surtout les îles
australes c'est la plus grande réserve
naturelle française d'accord donc c'est
à la fois une réserve marine mais c'est
aussi parce que la mer était comprise
mais dans ce dans cette aire protégée
leurs protégés qui aujourd'hui depuis le
début de cette année équivaut à peu près
à 1,6 million de kilomètres carrés donc
ce qui en fait la plus grande réserve
naturelle française est un des plus
grands sanctuaires marins au monde on
enchaîne donc avec ces photos donc sur
les îles crozet et donc ça y est là on
est on est on est toujours sur les îles
creuser là et bien là on est à l'abbé
américaine on est on est assis dans son
appel à b américaine sur l'île de la
possession à crozet process et c'est
plusieurs îles certaines sont
inaccessibles sauf de très rares cas de
recherche scientifique etc notamment
l'ill aux cochons qui on suspecte abrite
la plus grande colonie de manchots
royaux au monde mais de toute façon les
îles australes sont connus pour les
manchots sont les manchots royaux vous
avez un petit côté sylvain tesson là je
n'en ferais du tout assis comme ça
regardez vous est superbe avec ban
s'était vanté son sera très content donc
c'est pas des c'est pas des pingouins
cédant des manchots de la fusion à ne
pas faire alors c'est quoi la différence
et ben c'est simple pas loin c'est
l'hémisphère nord et ça ressemble en
général pas du tout à ce que les gens ou
en tête pour ton 10 points le monde
d'accord et les manchots sont ce à quoi
on a en tête entre nous il ne dit pas
loin et c'est l'hémisphère sud d'accord
donc nous sommes dans l'hémisphère sud
donc nous sommes mon royaume à des
manchots royaux qui sont les deuxièmes
plus gros mon show derrière les manchots
empereurs que les gens connaissent
beaucoup à cause d'eux enfin grâce
plutôt à la marche de l'empereur avec
directement cette photo donc allé là
votre photographe voilà c'est mélanie en
train de travailler durement abri
américaine et alors quand ça se passe
quand on est face à des animaux comme ça
qu'on n'a vraiment pas l'habitude de
voir alors en fait on n'a pas l'habitude
de les voir et ils ont pas l'habitude
trop non plus de nous voir donc en faire
un sont du coup très curieux est-ce que
les manchots à terre ont pas de
prédateurs naturels donc en fait c'est
ce qu'on appelle c'est ce que les
scientifiques appellent un milieu des
harmoniques donc en fait c'est une
équipe moins ça eh ben ils n'ont pas de
prédateurs sur terre donc c'est à dire
que quand ils vous voient ils n'ont peur
de rien sinon ils sont assez curieux
enfin si james opposé qu'on reste calme
ils sont assez curieux d'accord et et
c'est dangereux les manchots oui et non
pas du tout c'est adore donc je ne sais
pas parce que par exemple ne vous
frottez pas une oie par exemple non mais
ils peuvent ils peuvent vous donner des
petits coups avec leur zèle c'est pas
vrai d'accord d'accord d'accord bon
alors les manchots on continue à les
regarder alors après les creuser vous
reprenez toujours ce bateau ouais mais
là on est on est en fait là celle
arrivée à creuser en fait d'accord
l'arrivée à creuser donc là le marion
dufresne combien de personnes sur ce
bateau là qui transite alors ça dépend
parce qu'il ya des op qui enfin il ya
des noms qu'il ya des trajets qui sont
faits pour déposer des gens il ya des
trajets qui sont faits pour reprendre
des gens donc en fait ça dépend à quel
loupé on participe mais on peut avoir
jusqu'à une centaine de personnes sur le
bateau centaines de personnes sur sur ce
bateau ont continué donc là on est au
jour alors là on est pas on est à la
baie du marin d'un corps à creuser qui
est la tienne général et cette photo qui
est merci et hier encore at il une des
colonies les plus accessibles elle est
juste à côté de la base scientifique
donc on peut y aller assez facilement et
comme le marion dufresne mouiller en
général en face de la base scientifique
ça donne l'occasion ça c'est un peu la
photo que tout le monde fait à baie du
marin dakhla qu'elle est jolie mais tout
le monde l'a fait mais bon nous on la
voit pas tous les jours cette photo et
on continue alors on y va en avance oui
cette photo vous l'avez pris deux fois
elle vous plaît avec la corrosion je
viens vie elle est superbe on est où là
encore à crozet là on est on sait on est
depuis l'île de la possession on voit le
marion dufresne à gauche et en face
c'est l'île de l'est villes de l'est qui
a la plus grande falaise de france
d'accord a oui j'avais une idée de la
taille assez par quatre au total 1 ouais
ouais c'est 1080 mètres si je dis pas de
bêtises nous sommes en direct dans cette
soirée photos avec avec vincent joly qui
revient d des kerguelen et qui nous
propose de partager ses photos ses plus
belles photos ce qu'il a pu voir là bas
car galène faq album photo oui si vous
avez raison parce que vous avez écrit le
reportage que vous pouvez retrouver des
photos de votre de votre photographe
mélanie wenger c'est ça hein qui
d'ailleurs exposera ses photos 1 elle
expose ses photos au festival de la dia
si tout l'été dans le morbihan voilà
donc si vous êtes du morbihan vous
pourrez voir ces photos tout l'été on
continue on enchaîne ses photos elles
sont magnifiques vous voulez vous je
vous dise là vous avez vous rires non
mais c'est les manches c'est pas les
photos qui sont magnifiques et les
manchots royaux du village vous avez
raison vous êtes vraiment très proches
là mais en fait ils viennent nous voir
donc
c'est pas mal on peut les caresser ou
sans compliquer c'est pas c'est pas
conseil s'est pas conseillé les photos
suivantes alors on va essayer d'avancer
un petit peu donc on les a également ici
en plein en pleine mer j'ai là vous êtes
où vous êtes sur le bateau vous allez
ouais on est sur le pont du marion
dufresne ils sont venus nous dire
bonjour un matin donc on était assez
content oui j'imagine c'est assez
impressionnant dont nous parce que les
manchots c'est très gauche c'est très
maladroit il ya un peu l'idiot sur terre
vous voulez vous lever pour nous montrer
comment
peut-être plus tard par contre dans l'os
et des nageurs cd nageur exceptionnel
donc nous avons fait la réunion si j'ai
bien compris nous sommes montés l'un à
tromelin on descend reçu deux peut-être
qu'on peut en remontrer 7 cette carte
vous là je vais vouloir trouver comme ça
tout le monde peut bien visualiser ce
qu'ont ceux dont on ce dont on parle on
va retrouver cette carte tac elle est
ici je vous la montre voilà donc nous
sommes montés vous en tout cas moi j'ai
pas fait grand chose mais je voyage avec
mais on est soit on en est ainsi je
voyage avec vous ce soir et on air d'été
au nord ensuite on n'arrivait pas à la
trop vous n'arriverez pas à vous pensez
que je vais pas arriver à trouver car
dès l'année alors là on à kerguelen
quinzaine mais c'est quoi c'est cette
zone ici creuser par là est-ce que je
vais tomber dessus et vous
voilà donc là ça ce sont trois petites
créatures tout il ya les deux qui nous
intéressent celles du radier lounès et
celle là ici digne de la possession est
ce que des gens il y habite vraiment sûr
nolin non non non il ya une base
scientifique une base et la base
scientifique
alfred fort et il reste
problème tend à un mois deux mois six
mois ça dépend il ya ce qu'on appelle
des campagnards d'été qui ont pour l'été
austral donc l'équivalent de décembre à
avril pour nous et il ya les vsc par
contre ils peuvent y aller mais pour ce
qu'on appelle un hivernage les
hivernants donc ils restent en général
un an treize mois maximum en lan
les autorités des taaf
préfère ne pas laisser les gens trop
longtemps puisque c'est que l'on
aimerait c'est quand
j'ai lu ce que vous avez écrit dans
votre dans votre article c'est assez
étonnant ces personnes qui n'arrivent
pas à rentrer et parfois même on en
parlera un petit peu plus tard je
voudrais qu'on arrive aux kerguelen on
est toujours ici à à creuser un c'est ça
ou on aime pas trop serré c'est ça on
voulait pas partir de 3 ans clara crozet
franchement cette photo volée magnifique
je crois que c'est ma préférée dans
celle que vous m'avez envoyé eh ben
c'est bien ça tombe bien mais je sais
une photo de mélanie oui mais en même
temps c'est la photographe c'est une
bonne nouvelle c'est vraiment mais ce
serait embêtant de soirée merci de
partager ça avec nous avec nous ce soir
ces photos de man show et non pas de
pingouins contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire tient une pâte j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit une impasse
toussaint ça c'est un motard et un
éléphant de mer on et défendent maire a
alors ça que j'en avais eu beaucoup et
d'ailleurs c'est à une patte ça
s'appelle plus précisément il ya des
scientifiques appellent ça des palettes
natatoire alors parce que c'est assez
une sorte de nageoires en euros ça leur
sert pas vraiment grand chose c'est
plutôt avec leur queue en fait c'est ils
ont des mille îles ont des noms des
patins peu atrophiée des éléphants de
mer ça c'est des jeunes éléphants de mer
qu'on appelle des bonbons suisses ont
tour à tour au oui c'est vrai et les
orques aime bien des biens des croque et
ice ont eu pour le coup ils sont en
danger ils ont des prédateurs pas sur
terre tu vas sortir le faisons nous des
orques les auront pas encore appris à
marcher alors ils cohabitent ils
cohabitent avec les avec les manchots
ceux là où ils sont sur les mêmes plages
l'accord de temps en temps d'ailleurs
sur les colonies de manchots s'est passé
pas rare de trouver des pachas ou des
who des éléphants de mer qui sont sur la
plage c'est ils cohabitent assez bien
c'est quoi les températures
ces îles basses ça dépend si on est en
hiver ou alors vous vous y êtes allé à
quel moment nous on est allé pendant
l'été austral donc il fait frais mais il
fait au soleil il fait bon il fait bon
c'est à dire vous êtes quand même avec
une veste un obligatoire ou pas comme en
fait dans pas ce que c'est stralman il
fait pas 35 degrés là non il fait pas 35
jurés mais enfin c'est surtout le vent
qui est assez rare à 100 sur les îles
australes d'accord c'est un vent
permanent qui ne s'arrête jamais
vraiment jamais jamais difficile donc de
n'imagine de vivre tranquillement il ya
ce bruit tout le temps j'imagine dans
les oreilles de oued
sebbah d'ailleurs c'est ce que les
hivernants souvent nous disent c'est à
dire que de temps en temps
le vent peut être assez fatigant parce
que c'est effectivement toujours un
bruit de fond permanent
mais après il ya aussi des cons là on y
faisait beau mais quand le temps se gâte
ça peut être problématique superbes
photos on est on est où là on aligne de
l'est line voulait toujours pareil
combien de temps combien de temps vous
avez fait sur ces cinq semaines combien
de temps avant d'arriver aux kerguelen à
peu près de deux semaines et puis on est
arrivé à el harti le 1er décembre 2021
et on est arrivé à tyr violaine si je me
trompe pas le 15 ou le 16 décembre avec
toujours cette vie sur sur ce bateau
qu'est ce que c'est c'est le seul arbre
de l'île de crozet qui a porté ce qu'il
n'y a pas d'arbres sur les îles
australes enfin il ya des arabes il ya
des arbres sur amsterdam mais attire
vielen et sur crozet n'y a pas d'arbres
et ça c'est un art un pommier qui a été
planté et ya été mis sous une serre et
donc sous serre pourra jamais donné de
pommes d'accord mais vous me prenez
quelques dons impossible mais aucune
végétation non non non en fait à la base
un but d'erding dans l'histoire des
idées australie a eu un moment où
il ya eu des tentatives d'agriculture
qui on est et qui ont été faites pour
voir si on pouvait cultiver des bas
voilà cultiver des fruits des légumes de
la nourriture même si on a essayé
d'intégrer des bovins d'accord voir si
on pouvait développer une agriculture
sur ces îles et en fait ça n'a jamais
pris vous réagissez évidemment sur
lefigaro.fr surtout sur youtube si vous
voulez poser des questions à vincent
joly sur ce voyage et ce reportage dans
les terres australes re dites-moi ce que
ça veut dire des tailleurs australes et
antarctiques françaises voici nous dont
font partie les kerguelen c'est vrai que
c'est un nom un peu un peu mythique
qu'est ce qu'on va y arriver assez assez
kerguelen quand même peut-être aller on
essaye avec encore trop tôt magnifique
oui mais vous avez adoré en fait passer
les manchots c'est quand même une itt de
voir ça vous avez bien raison et alors
pourquoi entre eux n'est pas de la même
couleur la c1 juvénile pendant très
longtemps d'ailleurs quand on a
découvert cette espèce pendant très
longtemps des enfin les premières les
premières années où les scientifiques
ont découvert ces espèces on pensait que
les juvéniles donc les bébés manchots
royaux était en fait une espèce à part
aa d'accord parce qu'ils sont vraiment
très différent où ils peuvent faire à
peu près la même taille même si ce n'est
plus petit et donc là on le voit un peu
il en train de perdre sa collage marron
et des gta tournoi je n'y ai tout dit
deviendra comme en fait la une en train
de réclamer de la nourriture à sont mis
d'accord c'est le sait les adultes qui
nourrissent les petits d'accord et sera
en fête avec son pelage là il peut pas
encore nager il peut pas nager dans
d'accord et parce que ils naissent sur
terre cela vraiment d eau dans des oeufs
oui j'imagine que c'est un oiseau un
oiseau d'accord donc les manchots
juvénile les bébés finalement un essai
superbe ces images encore très proche là
il ya combien vous avez vous savez
combien vous avez des manchots autour de
vous c'est plusieurs milliers ça dépend
des colonies sur rakhmanov qu'on verra
un peu après sur cardy règne quand on y
arrivera ces deux cent mille manchots
sur une plage 200000 man show ça se fait
ça fait du bien on a une idée
combien on peut trouver de manchots sur
l'ensemble de ses terres australes et
antarctiques françaises je n'ai pas de
chiffres en tête mais on estime que l'on
sait pratiquement la première sinon la
deuxième que le population de manchots
royaux dans le monde
ont toutes les îles australes avec ses
photos alors excusez moi est ce qu'ils
sont en train de se reproduire car le
reste est une reproduction et à vous
confirmer avec avec ed des voisins un
peu curieux s commis alors ce sont des
pratiques je sais pas si vous avez les
mêmes en tout cas et on peut
différencier facilement comme sale oeil
le mal de la teneur en guyane il ya très
peu de ce qu'on appelle de dimorphisme
sexuel y en a on a vraiment très pesant
sur cette espèce on continue donc avec
ces on arrive à tire d'ailés à kerguelen
alors quand même je voudrais vous lire
si vous le voulez bien parce que c'est
comme ça que vous commencez votre votre
reportage il est là quelque part dans
l'obscurité d'une nuit surchauffé le cac
bourbon de l'archipel kerguelen attend
de se dévoiler à nos yeux fatigués grâce
à la faveur d'un éclat lunaire déchirant
les nuages tranchants les tempétueuse
ténèbres des 40e rugissants comme une
lame le navire marion dufresne
transperce les vagues gonflé d'une mère
bouillonnante à travers les vitres du
navire l'épaisse obscurité semble
brûlante les souffles des cubes se
confondent avec de la vapeur le bruit
d'une chaise valdingue contre les murs
de notre cabine sous le coup du roulis
nous arrache à cette contemplation
magique du noir abyssal bon il y en a
qui savent écrire c'est bon que je n'en
sais
pas du tout c'est un peu tout et pas du
tout alors je suis sûr que les gens qui
viennent d'entendre ça se disent il faut
à tout prix que j'allais lire ce
reportage donc on a tellement c'est très
bien on est on est aux aguets veine
raconté - qu'est-ce que c'est alors ça
c'est port jeanne d'arc et c'est génial
parce que port jeanne d'arc c'est la
seule usine baleinière jamais construite
sur le pôle sur le pardon sur le sol
français usine baleinière les bas
c'était ça a été un point d'eux
2 transformations de chasse à la baleine
et les éléphants de mer pour en faire on
utilisait leur graisse pour faire du
savon de l'huile etc c'était vraiment il
ya un siècle mais alors là je danse que
je vois il n'y a pas de
y'a pas de baleines ça n'existe plus à
non non non évidemment on a arrêté elle
a été opérationnelle au début du 20e
siècle entre si je me trompe pas entre
1909 et
1920 voilà une baleinière ah non à
l'accord
excusez moi vous m'aviez dit que vous
faisiez pas le pingouin non là le
manchot le manchot ou alors dans le
manchot ben voilà ça c'est un bel
exemple de ce qui se passe quand il ya
des soirées arrosées sur le marion
dufresne le marion dufresne est un lieu
de fête c'est bien quand c'est un bas
bien sûr ben ça fait partie ont fait un
peu et c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont du mal à revenir à on
peut passer on n'est pas obligé cgnews
elle alors apple est la suivante mais
regardez on
va rester un peu là dessus parce que je
suis sûr que ça va rester laisser
d'autres internautes de suivre ce live
vous nous partager votre photo de
reportage et de vacances excusez moi on
partage tout évidemment j'ai avoir séché
vraiment toujours ij
bah oui le marion dufresne sans certains
ont secret de toute façon c'est un lieu
de fête mais sur les districts aussi et
c'est ce qui fait partie aussi de et
c'est pour ça que les gens ont du mal à
revenir des australes et des taaf c'est
une ambiance particulière on est coupé
du monde on est avec les mêmes personnes
pendant des semaines des mois et c'est
donc bas et puis c'est quand même assez
génial on est on est à bord d'un navire
on est au bout du monde on est en train
on est dans les quarantièmes rugissants
le bateau roule le mal de mer
il ya eu il ya eu une journée c'était
pas facile ouais il ya des jours où
certains jours c'est un petit peu y
avait il ya des jours où c'est le
bouillon quoi bon aller j'enchaîne même
si je me délecte aller 3 2 1 vous est
superbe sur cette photo et on continue
ici donc eh bien on sera dans les alpes
non ah oui c'est vrai que ça ressemble
migros quelle altitude vous avez une
idée maj de pièges complètement mais
c'est le point culminant de kerguelen et
dont des îles australes vous avez pu
tourner autour si j'ai bien compris là
c'est pendant une rotation n'a eu
l'occasion en fait c'est guardian end là
on a eu beaucoup de chance parce le
tiers des laines c'est normalement très
nuageux et le ciel est rarement dégagé
et quand le ciel est dégagé par contre
on peut voir le mot russie envoie un arc
en ciel dans ça c'est en fait parce
qu'on n'a pas pu ouvrir la fenêtre de
l'hélicoptère donc c'est d'accord donc
je me fais pièce les justes français
vous auriez dû me vendre l'histoire
s'est
noyé vous avez raison c'est vrai que ça
ressemble plutôt à un reflet on enchaîne
en est où à port aux français qui est la
base
principale est l'unique base d'ailleurs
de kerguelen qui se trouve dans le golfe
du morbihan d'ailleurs donc quand vous
me dites
le golfe du morbihan
pourquoi kerguelen d'ailleurs c'est ce
nom et ben parce que cardia laine
l'archipel a été découvert il ya pile
poil 2 105 longtemps
en février 1772 art un navigateur
missionné par louis 15 qui devait
chercher le continent antarctique et ya
trouvé à la place l'archipel kerguelen
donc on lui a donné ce nom d'ailleurs à
la base ce n'était pas un compliment ce
qui en fait car d'hélène était un peu un
filou dont kerguelen il a dit découvrent
ils découvrent l'archipel c'est une
terre complètement sinistré il rentre en
france et il dit qu'il a trouvé une
terre formidable avec plein avait des
gens au dessus qui sont très
accueillants avec une terre luxuriante
et ses comptes il ment à la cour pour
refinancer une expédition il retourne là
bas il retourne là bas une deuxième fois
et en fait ce qui est drôle c'est que le
clan cook l'autre explorateur anglais we
et célèbres voilà pas s'attarder l'aisne
ça s'appelle les îles de la désolation
et alors c'est là où l'histoire est un
peu capricieuse on sait pas vraiment
s'il le fait pour se moquer de tirades
jelen ou pour lui rendre hommage mais
coûte renomment les îles de la
désolation les îles kerguelen des îles
kerguelen donc et
vous me dites le port finalement c'est
le village en français c'est la base aux
scientifiques qui abrite on va dire
jusqu'à une centaine de personnes ont
classé les bâtiments il ya le bâtiment
principal avec le bar qui s'appelle
totoche à vous le connaissez le bar le
bas âge et que je connais tous les bars
des îles australes finalement doit pas y
avoir beaucoup d'ail en a un par de
street on est où là alors là je peux
vraiment on a fait un bon on a foncé
avec ça on va on va avancer on est
toujours sur ce marion dufresne la la
c'est une séance de yoga sur la dz doit
être très intéressant oui mais non mais
ça montre qu'il ya une vie et qu'on a
c'est la dimension
vous avez vécu à bord comme on arrive à
kerguelen là c'est ça là on est celle
arrivée à tire d'ailés là on comprend
peut-être les îles de la désolation dont
on voit cette image voilà là c'est pas
accueillants c'est ce que vous décrivez
là dans ce que j'ai lu finalement c'est
ça qu'on voit quelle est l'ambiance
l'atmosphère ce que vous avez j'imagine
fait plusieurs jours vous nous l'avez
dit d'être voyage et vous arrivé là vous
savez que c'est presque le bout du monde
là ça en fait j'étais isolé du monde ce
qui est génial en plus c'est que l'on a
fait on a fait ce reportage un peu à
l'occasion des 250 ans de la découverte
donc on a lu on a lu l'histoire de tyard
d'hélène enfin d'une pierre dulaine le
navigateur donc en fait c'était très
émouvant finalement c'est de savoir
qu'on ait deux cent cinquante ans là où
il a été et donc on peut on imagine ce
qu'il a dû imaginer et surtout face aux
kerguelen la première fois il met pas le
pied à terre la première fois c'est son
enseigne qui prend possession de cardy
laine au nom du roi qui s'appelle
l'ancien pardon l'ancienne l'enseigne de
bois bois des boîtiers match est à la
base il a l'impression de découvrir
l'antarctique en fait ils pensent qu'ils
découvrent le continent le continent
fantasmer sinon australe métier à
l'épaule chance s'appelle pas en partie
d'accord mais ce continent il est très
petit mais on s'en rend vite compte
j'imagine à l'époque oui mais il faut se
mettre à sa place à sa place il ya pas
les satellites ya pas yaya rien ni paris
par de l'île bourbon qui est l'actuel
l'île maurice et puis comme ça il va au
sud il va au sud il va monsieur il tombe
sur cette terre mais à l'époque on n'a
pas les cartes complètes qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc c'est logique qu'ils
pensent avoir trouvé le continent
antarctique par contre là où c'est pas
logique c'est il revient et qui dit il a
trouvé une terre formidable alors je
sais quand même un caillou milieu de
l'océan à être orientés pousse à aller
menteur un bon là on vient dans le coeur
du sujet avec cette photo vous allez me
l'a décrit à m'expliquer un un petit
c'est bon un petit bug mais on voit
qu'on va on va régler ça oui mais la
crise de la transmission se fait pas et
ça d'ailleurs c'est les cds le radôme
autour des antennes de galileo le gps
européen
ce qui à galène c'est principalement une
terre où on fait de la recherche
scientifique eh bien ça expliquez-nous
on y fait quoi à quoi ça sert à la
france finalement à quoi ça sert à la
france sa sert a plein de choses à la
france déjà c'est grâce à des
territoires extra marins comme ça donc
kerguelen évidemment mais la réunion
l'île maurice du tout mais la réunion
tous nos territoires d'outre-mer et nos
territoires et stramare un fonds que la
france aujourd'hui c'est la deuxième
c'est le deuxième pays à avoir la plus
grande zone économique exclusive au
monde après les etats-unis zone
économique exclusive au monde oui mais
on fait qu'elle économisait déjà déjà ça
nous donne ça nous donne une
souveraineté marine la deuxième
souveraineté marines au monde a donc
très importante en déjà pas mal donc
tous une très grande partie du pacifique
et contrer la syrie car on est dans
l'océan indien dans l'océan indien par
ben oui raison de me reprendre oui
quelle erreur dans l'océan indien est
contrôlé par la france grâce à ces
contrôles est en tout cas c'est nos eaux
territoriales françaises alors qu'est ce
qu'on y fait là par exemple sur sept est
en fait alors la position de saisir
elles sont très intéressantes parce
qu'on est sûr si vous remettez la carte
vous remarquerez que voulait la carte
allez-y je vous la montre je pense que
l'on va tout de suite comprendre si vous
désormais oui oui je vais dézoomer
allons-y up ont des hommes et on voit là
ensemble cette carte et ben si vous
mettez votre souris sur terre dit allen
ouais bah on est un endroit du globe où
il ya aucune terres émergées
donc bas pour un réseau satellite
satellitaires comme galileo avoir des
antennes à cet endroit là c'est
vachement pratique alors aux 13 ans les
galileo galileo c'est le gps européen
donc expliquez moi parce que je suis pro
êtes vous avez le gps oui le gps et un
réseau de positionnement par satellite
grâce aux américains
l'europe à développer quelque chose qui
s'appelle galileo et le réseau de
positionnement par satellites européen
c'est une alternative au gps et il est
il est sur cette île non il est il et
s'il ya des satellites dans l'espace oui
bien sûr et à terre on a besoin
d'antenne d'accord pouvoir évidemment
capter affiner le signal eh ben c'est
utile d'avoir une antenne à cet endroit
là puisque on quadrille la loi aubry
bien sûr bien que plus d'antennes
possible dans le plus d'endroits précis
donc pour l'europe pour ce système c'est
vachement majeur d'avoir d'ailleurs la
moitié des antennes de galileo ouais
donc de l'europe la moitié de ces
antennes se trouvent sur le territoire
français d'accord apprenez quelque chose
bon alors qu'est ce qu'ont fait d'autres
surveillent si vous remettez la photo il
ya le ballon qui entendent être gonflé
avec je sais
alors moi vous savez je fais ça je mets
les dès lors des lampions puis c'est
magnifique ah non c'est pas pour ça
c'est une sonde météo à d'accord ça
c'est grâce à ça on a des président et
des prévisions météorologiques
formidable ah mais oui mais alors les
prévisions météo fait à kerguelen la ssr
va beaucoup de gens parce qu'en fait ça
permet d'affiner les modèles
météorologiques donc par exemple eh ben
ça peut servir à détecter des tempêtes
la force du vent les précipitations qui
vont ensuite arrivé vers vers les côtes
de pays un peu plus le pied bon ça sert
à plein de choses les idées oui
j'imagine et on va continuer à en parler
bonjour à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
sur facebook le figaro.fr tweet vous
nous posez vos questions
vincent joly est là pour vous répondre
il revient de cinq semaines c'est ça
cinq semaines pour faire le tour des taf
ces fameux territoire iso strahl des taf
c'est compliqué difficile 1 je pense que
les gens ne savent pas du tout ce que ça
veut dire est-ce que c'est pas très peu
comment vous est venue l'idée tient
partir là-bas et ben au figaro on
cherche toujours des
sujets formidable pour nos lecteurs et
on les trouve et on est on les lit
l'expérience est unique c'est ce que
vous écrivez est profondément marquante
pour certains et l'un de vos
interlocuteurs vous dit il y en a qui ne
reviennent jamais vraiment des taf
expliquez moi ce que ça veut dire et ben
en fait c'est un passage qui est
tellement particulier dans la vie d'un
individu en hivernage encore une fois
faut s'imaginer on est alors on n'est
plus coupée du monde parce que
maintenant il ya internet mais on l'est
quand même c'est à dire qu'il ya
internet mais il est pas il est pas
partout il est pas sur toutes les bases
la plupart des gens même ceux qui
volontairement et on est sur un bout de
caillou avec
au bout du monde alors soit il y en a
ils vont pour faire de la plomberie ce
qu'il faut maintenir les pas forcément
des scientifiques qu'ils sont
des maçons et charpentiers maçons
charpentiers pour se faire construire
des cabanes pour
les bases scientifiques et sur les îles
il ya des cabanes qui servent en fait de
point de logistique pour les
scientifiques qui font des recherches
et bah c'est assez marquant dans une vie
il se passe plein de choses on se dit
quand même une aventure qui est
exceptionnel donc après reprendre le
bateau et se replonger dans le monde
réel bah c'est pas forcément facile
d'ailleurs même pour nous ça n'a pas été
là jusqu'au bout de cinq semaines la
seule chose plus rare que de venir dans
les taaf c'est de pouvoir y retourner
parce que quand on y va il est quasiment
impossible de rouler dans la plupart des
gens au niveau qu'une fois après ce que
je vous disais il ya vraiment une
poignée d'élus soit de l'institut
polaire soit de la réserve et cetera qui
ont la chance de pouvoir participer à
plusieurs rotations dans leur vie il ya
il ya des directeurs de programmes
scientifiques ali pev qui ont eu la
chance de travailler dans les terres
australes pendant pendant 20 ans ont les
couilles c'est vraiment vraiment de la
chance à ils ont de la chance mais il
faut le vouloir de s'isoler comme ça
aussi pendant pendant des années parce
que ce qu'il peut y avoir des familles à
des gens comme vous c'est marrant des
travailleurs plus maintenant plus depuis
des années 1950 on avance dans ces
photos on est où là avec cette photo a
encore des photos petit souci là c'est
notre dame des vents s'il ya une église
à tiers des gènes qui s'appelle l'église
notre-dame des vents kerguelen donc on
ne sait pas notre dame des vents ça
c'est des éléphants de mer oui oui je
les reconnais alors il a il fonde la
thermorégulation social alors
expliquez-moi ce que c'est la
thermorégulation sociale
là je vois qui se montent dessus
principalement en fait les éléphants de
mer reviennent à terre et ils vont donc
en fait ils perdent ils
on a une photo wenn l'appelle là-bas
c'est ce qu'on appelle une mue
catastrophique donc y perdre
l'intégralité de leur peau et plantes y
perdre l'intégralité de leur peau en
fait ça alors c'est à leur demande ils
consomment beaucoup d'énergie dont ils
deviennent plus sensibles au froid donc
pouvoir avoir moins froid et ben attia
ce qu'ils font ils font comme nous ils
se collent et ils font de la semaine
appel de la thermorégulation social
thermorégulation social drôle de terme
au scrabble ça fait un malheur
on en voit partout donc engouement
mecelec de photos qui m'a fait le plus
rire c'est les colocataires de céder
claudia terre des habitants de port aux
français quand on est loin enfin ces
éléphants de mer vivent dans la mer ils
gagnent à terre il vient à terre alors
les leçons mois l'éléphante parler du
manchot parlons l'éléphant demeures
éléphants de mer il est formidable ah ah
je vous avais d'affinités toute
particulière avec les défendre les
réformes mer il est formidable
l'éléphant de mer il passe deux mois à
terre et le reste du temps il est en mer
mais par contre deux mois par an il
revient notamment pendant l'été austral
il revient pour se reproduire pour mu et
c est donc lentilles reviennent à terre
là c'est un très jeune éléphant de mer
c'est un tout petit on n'a pas eu de
chance de voir on n'a pas de pacha en
photo mais les pachas ils peuvent faire
jusqu'à 4 tonnes les vaches à lait pas
chasser les matures ils ont ils ont un
et c'est pour ça qu'ils s'appellent les
éléphants de mer les éléphants de mer
masculin développe un nez tiassé on vers
un trait protubérants est comme une
sorte de trompe c'est pour ça qu'on a
des appels des éléphants de mer route
dangereuse vous voyez ici ça c'est le
panneau à célèbre deux tiers des lignes
que tout le monde en fait c'est vrai
c'est assez drôle et puis là vous l'avez
vu vous avez eu la chance d'avoir un
éléphant de mer au pied qui vous
symbolise transfère son jeu derrière ils
sont tout le temps la haye sur tout le
temps là ils sont tout le temps et c'est
vrai qu'on doit faire attention sur la
route et on a vu la moto avant il faut
faire très attention à des voitures la
base sur le surcoût est devenu que les
voitures et même un camion de pompier
d'accord et oui par exemple lorsqu'il ya
la police qui régale m ce qui est un
maire est ce qui est une alors la pleine
mer il ya en fait dès son appel des
chefs de districts qui sont en fait les
représentants du préfet administrateur
des terres australes et antarctiques
françaises d'accord voilà d'alors jiang
un préfet il ya un préfet visiteurs la
préfecture elle est basée à saint pierre
à la réunion
et le préfet administrateur en fait
elles représentant de l'état sur ces sur
ces territoires mais le préfet va pas
passer tout ça tout son mandat sur des
bouts de cailloux non donc si on nomme
sont nommés des chefs de districts qui
sont ils font office de douaniers de
père de mère c'est d'ailleurs eux qui
tiraient tu perds il me semble que c'est
eux qui récupère nos passeports quand on
arrive sur sur les terres australes
quel est le statut précisément c'est un
département c'est un territoire autonome
est ce que vous êtes en danger les su
basse et une préfecture déjà fin c'est
des territoires là je n'ai pas envie de
dire non mais vraiment je vous pose la
question alors parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que moi j'ai voulu faire ce
live en direct en tout temps on n'a pas
discuté avant vous m'avez envoyé les
photos et puis on s'est dit je veux être
comme les internautes qui sont qui nous
regarde et vous me raconter ce qui s'est
passé on fait cette soirée photos
ensemble vous me parlez il ya un instant
de la peau des éléphants mer c'est ce
qu'on voit là finalement ils sont en
train d errière on voit un peu on voit
un peu effectivement placé à la pesée
alors là c'est mon équipe de
scientifiques oui c'est ça qu'on fait à
jardiner c'est comme ça qu'on passe ses
journées on pèse deux éléphants de mer
alors en fait là c'est une pose de
balises donc en fait les scientifiques
de l'institut polaire vont sélectionner
un éléphant de mer sur laquelle ils vont
poser une balise et cette balise elle va
permettre en fait d'aller de pouvoir
explorer les fonds marins c'est quand
même assez génial donc la sélection d'un
candidat qui va sur lequel on va poser
une balise j'ai vu vous vous dites dans
votre dans votre reportage que vous
pouvez retrouver un sur sur lefigaro.fr
il ya un malaise chez les scientifiques
en ce moment pourquoi ils ont
l'impression que c'est de la cuisine
interne des terres australes ah oui mais
ça m'intéresse c'est à dire que
historiquement c'est un lieu de science
finalement pour la france et
et on les empêche de faire leur boulot
non les empêche pas du tout de faire
leur boulot en fait c'est mais c'est un
c'est un débat qui est ya pas lieu tout
sur les terres australes c'est un débat
qui a lieu partout c'est en fait comment
on concilie la recherche scientifique
sur l'environnement donc la faune et la
flore en l'occurrence aka et la
conservation et la défense de
l'environnement et de temps en temps ces
deux causes qui qui peuvent très bien
s'épouser meti d'autant de temps en
temps peuvent un peu s'entrechoquer je
vous lis également vous dites qu'il ya
un système de nettoyage des vêtements et
des équipements qui vise à endiguer la
propagation des espèces exogènes sur des
écosystèmes ça veut dire que c'est
écologie à tout va à carignan fait alors
sa part d'une très bonne intention serge
c'est vrai que le départ les hommes ont
fait un peu n'importe quoi en arrivant
sur sur des sûr qu'ils reviennent et les
australes ce qu'il faut savoir c'est les
milieux insulaires surtout des nuances
eu les insulaires comme ça où l'homme
vraiment est je pense à mon âge on était
très clairement pas censé arriver là bas
sont ces des petites bulles est donc
temps l'homme arrive est bien l'homme
ils arrivent avec des graines des
animaux pleins de choses et donc on
n'altère ces écosystèmes par exemple les
chats a alors la question des chaouis
vous me dites les chats véritable fléau
pour les oiseaux de kerguelen qui n'ont
jamais été habitué à être chassés par
des félins a bien sûr expliqué mme moore
c'est un problème donc l'homme arrive à
tire d'aile m il arrive à tire d'aile n
est qu est ce qu on fait ce qu'on amène
souvent avec un bateau eh ben on a même
des rats on amène des rongeurs dont dans
les années 50 les scientifiques il en
avait ras le bol d'avoir des rongeurs
donc est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
amené des chats simplement les chats ils
sont reproduits mais ça c'est l'histoire
de sur beaucoup de dcl au système
insulaire le chat est un est un fléau en
écologie enfin en écologie on va dire
dans la conservation d'ailleurs un thé
et c'est à dire que le chat est un être
un félin donc le cha chas donc le
problème des chats à kerguelen et alors
j'ai vu que on est obligé d'en tuer
certains barons le but c'est de les
éradiquer
complètement les jeunes parce que c'est
des chats sauvages on n'a pas le droit
d'avoir des humains des animaux de
compagnie à kari helene à la base ils
ont ils étaient là pour iliad et rennes
aussi à calais l'aisne deir el bayadh et
rennes il ya déjà des mouflons sa
expliquez moi pourquoi les bains parce
qu en fait il ya eu des expériences de
fait sur ces deux ans je voulais 10 sur
les australes on a un peu fait n'importe
quoi c'était à une aussi à une époque où
on n'avait pas la même conscience
écologique on a aujourd'hui
donc voilà il est on est toujours tenté
de regarder le passé les juger avec le
critère du présent en fait c'est la
faute de personne à l'époque il y avait
moins de pensée écologique et mon art
introduit
toute une série d'animaux qui n'avaient
rien à faire sur ces écosystèmes le
lemur twitch qui nous dit il n'y a pas
de mer juste un éléphant de mer en chef
cette petite blague non mais j'ai rien
compris mais non on a parlé du maire
vous n'écoutez pas du tout joli nous
sommes en direct si vous nous rejoignez
pour une soirée photos avec vincent joly
qui revient d'un très long voyage cinq
semaines c'était au mois de décembre oui
déjà on va descendre mais on raconte ce
voyage et vous montrer toutes toutes vos
photos je vous propose qu'on continue si
vous le voulez bien avec ces photos qui
sont qui sont évidemment superbe alors
donc nous sommes là devant voilà une
plage remplie vous vous demandez à quoi
ça ressemble 200000 mon show et bah ça
ressemble à ça deux cent mille manche
ouais c'est pas mal et là vous êtes vous
pouvez marcher au milieu comme ça non
c'est pas conseillée surtout à ce moment
là parce qu'en fait bon là ce qu'on voit
peut-être pas bien
c'est qu'il ya des endroits où ils sont
en train de couver l'oeuf à d'alors non
plus mais de toute façon on essaye de ne
pas les déranger même si on les dérange
pas vraiment parce qu'ils s'en foutent
et on va pas rentrer dans la mêlée pour
pour coréen pour courir au milieu même
même si c'est assez tentant quand même
sinon on dirait la côte d'azur en plein
gré d'autres frais un oui c'est le
touquet
plateau où est charlie où est charlie la
voile à bahia ce qu'on voit c'est tient
juvénile qui a un peu perdu mais on le
voit comme le rappelle si vous nous
rejoignez venus à celui c'est le bébé
finalement c'est un voleur qu'est ce
qu'on ressent pas ce que vous partez
pour travailler pour travailler vincent
mais quand on est là bas est ce qu'on
profite on voyage et on sait c'est
une chance unique c'est une chance
unique mais ce qui est ce qui est génial
en fait c'est que on est on est au 21ème
siècle on a l'impression d'avoir connu
de la planète raid avoir apprivoisé
notre planète complètement et il ya
encore des quelques endroits dans le
monde comme ça où on a l'impression
d'être un peu de siècle en arrière quoi
une question peut-être remettre mais on
dit à kari helene aux kerguelen c'est un
peu compliqué en fait normalement on
devrait dire l'archipel kerguelen
d'accord non vous ne devrait pas dit
mais bon tout le monde dit au guardian
et le figaro a publié deux d'ailleurs
attire des néo tiers des laines donc
vous n'avez pas tranché finalement c'est
dans cette question moi j'aime bien les
deux cette photo
ces cabanes c'est là on est à huit
heures et une des cabanes mythique de
l'institut polaire français inquiets au
bord de la colonie de rakhmanov d'accord
on sait une cabane qui permet aux
scientifiques de dormir et de se lever
au pied de la de la fameuse colonies
convient de voir des 200 milles man show
exceptionnel des images donc de vous
m'avez dit le nom mélanie wenger mélanie
wenger mais le nom de la salle
qu'on salue évidemment mélanie on le
rappelle c'est elle qui fait toutes ces
photos et qui est parti en reportage
avec vincent mais le nom de la cabane
médiateur en fait toutes les cabanons
des nous d'accord contient mortadelle
iliad geither diamanche ou d'ailleurs
ça n'a aucun sens d'ailleurs on choisit
comme ça guetteurs guetteur oui parce
qu'on peut plus simple morceau nages si
on regarde une carte de tiers de l'aisne
il ya plein de noms toutes les îles ont
des noms et en fait c'est assez amusant
c'est de savoir c'est de s'intéresser et
personne n'a vraiment la réponse parler
notre monsieur qui est ce ça c'est sa
fière c'est un nos amis qu'on a qu'on a
rencontrés assurent qu'ils reviennent
c'est un marin messieurs dont il ya les
eaux tous les corps d'armées sont
représentés sur interviennent d'accord
il donc c'est un marc qui a qui a
postulé pour être en hivernage sur
carlen donc pour représenter la marine
française d'accord donc lui il travaille
second maître je crois si certains c'est
un militaire fait un militaire qui
siégeait sur place il fait quoi il fait
quoi et bien il assure la souveraineté
de la france
c'est marrant quand même il assurait
souveraineté de la forme et travaille un
peu quand ils travaillent soient aussi
la wii c'est un marin et on se déplace
une fois qu'on est à dire délai non
quand le marion dufresne il repart eh
bien il ya plus de débit plus clair donc
on se déplace en bateau
comme là où on va sur l'île de mayenne
avec des ornithologues
ce sont ce qu'on appelle les infra c'est
ça qu'est ce que ça veut dire les alors
l'envié alors il ya les militaires ouais
les sciences ce qu'on appelle les les wc
ipev ou résine est donc raisonnable pour
réserves naturelles et les infra
en fait c'est les travailleurs détachés
dont tu ça peut être
long on a parlé des plombiers les
charpentiers des menuisiers des
tous les métiers dont on peut avoir
besoin sur les sur les îles comment on
se nourrit dans ces îles et bâle grâce à
marion dufresne tiens tiens apportent
des vivres ce que vraiment rien ne
pousse la barre rien si des choux il ya
le chou de car del end à cordes on peut
manger le football est plus qualité
local c'est le chou et on peut manger du
foot gardienne et s est montré chez moi
je vais peut-être on pèche aussi bien
sûr où pêcher à tergnier aisne en
respectant des quotas évidemment mais on
peut pêcher mais qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que c'est que cette photo expliquez moi
alors là c'est christophe barbereau qui
est un c'est une sommité de
l'ornithologie française voilà étiez en
train de alors il me semble que là c'est
un prion de bershire mais je saurai on
est sur l'île de man est l'un des
paradis pour les autres pour les
ornithologues deux tiers des laines et
sur lesquels ils ont un programme de
suivi des espèces donc les manchots
principalement les éléphants de mer et
beaucoup d'oiseaux enfin j'ai vu
beaucoup de photos de man show c'est des
oiseaux ah oui vous avez raison vous
avez raison donc quand on est en haut
lieu on se regarde les ornithologues
s'occupe des manchots ont continué vous
les voyez regarder cet oiseau rare il
semble que c'est un prion beaux lots
là je sais qu'il me semble que c'est un
prion bleu ou une bêta prions bleus
cette fois j'ai pas dire de bêtises avec
avec donc le marion dufresne marion
dufresne c'est aussi le nom d'un
d'un explorateur c'est ça ouais marion
dufresne c'est le nom de l'explorateur
qui a découvert
je vais y arriver l'archipel de crozet
pas d'accord donc kerguelen a donné son
nom à lille et marion dufresne donné son
nom au bas mot qui amène à lille a alors
on est une petite photo qu'est ce que
c'est a malheureusement un petit souci à
s'expliquer moi c'est l'équipe est un
autre exemple de la vie à bord en fait
on est on s'occupe à bord quand même les
journées sont longues ouais et là on
avait fait les 25 heures du marion
dufresne ya des mois il y avait un vélo
électrique à bord et on s'est relayé
non-stop pendant 25 heures pour voir si
on pouvait pédaler plus de kilomètres
que 92
marié le marion pendant pendant 25
heures c'est pour ça cette superbe
cuisse que vous avez vous avez réussi ou
pas à faire plus à la vie est plus en
plus je crois qu'on a fait le triple de
ce qu'il va faire parce que pour aller
d'une île à une autre combien de temps
environ par exemple pour les deux îles
crozet kerguelen
c'est simple de la réunion a creusé ses
2800 km environ donc c'est quatre jours
de navigation
crozet kerguelen en fonction de la mer
c'est assez variable mais c'est à peu
près de 3000 km donc c'est encore trois
jours de navigation ou quatre
on arrive dans des parties glacière et
bah oui parce que le plus grand de
l'acier français n'est pas à chamonix de
glace de chamonix non non non c'est le
glacier f1 c'est la calotte glaciaire
même la coque qui est sur le lait entier
sur les versants
par l'ouest de cayenne c'est vrai que ça
ressemble un peu à la mer de glace de
chamonix voyez cette cuvette avec et là
c'est juste une des langues ça c'est le
glacier en père qui est un des de
l'acier qui font le plus vite en france
a donc lui aussi comme la mer de glace à
chamonix on voit ces images chaque année
2 le gc est rotules
là aussi elles mêmes problèmes ou des
colonies même hors zone sub antarctique
et surtout en zone sub antarctique c'est
un peu des vigies du réchauffement
climatique les îles australes et donc ça
c'est la langue du glacier en perd et on
parlait avec des scientifiques de l'ip
et 26 viennent depuis 15 ans aux îles
australes 20 ans même et ils le voient
ils ont vu en 20 ans recule énormément
essabah d'ailleurs voilà celle de
l'acier typhon le glas c'est qu'ils font
et ses photos assez impressionnante
toujours deux prises j'imagine depuis
l'hélicoptère
l'hélicoptère de qui est stationnée sur
le marion dufresne bears marion dufresne
il fait que ça y est
il fait faire des tours aux aux
personnes qui veulent aller sur l'ailé
taf où elle il a une autre utilité du
tout c'est le navire ravitailleur des
taf et ça c'est environ 120 jours par an
et le reste du temps il est il est co
affrété par l'ifremer pour des missions
océanographique
partout dans l'océan indien et sur la
planète cette photo vous avez de la
chance ça oui on a eu de la chance parce
que alors ça c'est une des éléphants de
mer c'est des otaries menée sur
amsterdam donc là on avance vous avez
quittez on a quitté dire les mais je
sens que vu lors des photos ou iron là
on est on a on a on a assisté à une mise
à bas de deux bébés otaries qu'on
appelle les puts les comment veux tu
loupes ce les pays ubs les petites
stations tout mignon voilà ce sur wii
j'avoue que c'est presse c'est presque
émouvant de voir c'est alors que alors
j'ai les otaries sont par contre très
très méchante a alors vous pouvez pas
les approcher comme proches quand même
mais c'est assez agressif une otarie
d'accord mais surtout dans ces
moments-là en forêt évidemment mais vous
avez quand même réussi à l'ani a réussi
à vous ah oui non vous vous avez le
choix reste élevé j'ai bien compris vous
êtes un peu peureux vous contenter
d'écrire à même les photos et puis en
fait c'est super ça c'est un albatros
superbe les albatros c'est magique c'est
un mal d'alcool à son fils jean pardon
vous pouvez me réciter le poème non non
non ne vous risquez pas j'ai bien
compris j'ai vu qu'eux on avez
on vit peut-être du côté de jeu s'est
passé l'état français de donner une
image très positive des kerguelen pas de
photos qui pourraient être dérangeante
expliqué là c'est un peu le
sa part est encore une fois c'est un
truc plus large en on a envie de donner
un peu
les gens ont du mal souvent à se rendre
compte que la nature c'est quelque chose
d'assez violent il ya de la prédation
bien voilà les la nature c'est pas
forcément que du disney et de temps en
temps dans les réserves naturelles on a
envie de présenter cette image très très
pure de la nature très pristine
mais bon en même temps c'est sublime
avion on avance et un allemand la saison
s'est inscrit à 1 comme un as quoi ce
tueur parce que vous êtes là alors vous
avez appris tout ça là bas où vous aviez
déjà des connaissances tous les
scientifiques ils sont là ils veulent
répondre à toutes vos questions là bas
c'est génial on apprend plein de choses
on imagine que vous avez découvert des
tas de chose qu'est ce que c'est eh ben
ça c'est ce qu'on sait ce qui se passe
en ce moment à la photographe de
photographier l'air pur parce que l'air
un désert les plus pures au monde
qu'est-ce que ça n'a aucun sens je veux
faire photographier l'air pur vous êtes
en train de me dire que vous avez réussi
bah ça voilà
mais qu'est ce que ça va être dit non en
fait concrètement vous savez il ya des
il ya des pour pour faire des relevés
atmosphériques et pourrait étudier un
peu l'état de notre atmosphère on parle
d'air pur c'est un peu un abus de
langage mais on doit avoir des stations
dans lequel il ya le moins de bruit de
fond à 2 atmosphérique d'accord un air
qui est le moins soumis aux masses
continentales donc avec le moins de
pollution avec les voilà ça et donc il
ya des endroits très précis et notamment
manolo à hawaï tient la plus connue qui
est là où on fait les fameux relevé de
pour déterminer le nombre de ppm dans
l'atmosphère les particules de carbone
est d'accord et attias à amsterdam à
pointe bénédicte c'est là où on est
ébahi lie à une de ces stations où il ya
soit voilà ce qu'on appelle un désert
les plus purs d'euros monde donc vous
avez respirer l'air le plus pur du monde
dont vous avez fait du vélo si j'ai bien
compris vous avez sur le bateau vous
avez à terre aussi on a fait du vélo à
tramelan acteurs aussi vous avez
respirer l'air le plus pur du monde vous
revenez de la barre et je n'ai rien
changé mais à changer carrément c1 c'est
une expérience et une espérance il ya il
ya des il ya des gens qui dépensent
jusqu'à 20000 euros pour avoir le
privilège de faire loupé qu'on a fait le
le menu sur tout ce qu'ils nous
demandent combien d'habitants et y at-il
dans l'archipel officiellement 0 y'a pas
d'habitants sur pas d'habitants donc
c'est que des visiteurs de vous des
travailleurs et des gens de passage et
alors combien de gens de passage au c'ur
kerviel on peut atteindre une centaine
de personnes trop vite sur trois et
amsterdam c'est encore plus petit on
dépasse rarement une vingtaine là on est
on est au kirsch et jean paul à saint
pol réserve intégrale on ne peut pas y
mettre les pieds à vous pouvez pas monté
sur cet îlot nom sur cette musique c'est
un nid logement car dit oui séance assez
en forme de croissant en plus c'est très
beau
toujours évidemment ce ce bateau qui a
été votre compagnon pendant toute cette
période les otaries les otaries
exceptionnel images et on voit
l'hélicoptère au fond ça là les superbes
d'otaries d'amsterdam ça s'est un peu
l'emblème assez l'emblème cha cha cha ni
mal de bas parce que voilà sur les
éléphants de mer c'est car d'hélène les
manchots s'est creusé et les otaries
c'est amsterdam les otaries à amsterdam
c'est rigolo ce nom et là vous êtes
aussi extrêmement prochain ouais c'est
avec mon iphone a donc vous trichez pas
ce que vous nous avez dit à l'instant
que que les otaries été un peu plus
agréables céder toutes ses ailes sont
mignonnes et sont toutes petites salles
à regarder ça ce sont des bébés c'est
l'époux pss et les deux mariés pour les
bébés otaries en avant cela on est de
retour à ternir leur tour et qui a l'air
et on continue on a on a vu toutes ces
photos voilà je voulais arriver à cette
photo vous nous en avait parlé tout à
l'heure mais expliquez nous il est en
train de changer lui c'est la mue
catastrophique de l'éléphant de mer mais
il va très bien on a l'impression qu'il
est pas content et il souffre mais c'est
un c'est parfaitement normal ils
changent chapeau et on voit ici
légalement saillie photo cette balise
alors
n'inquiéteront pas les associations qui
pourraient saisir cet animal souffre il
souffre pas là il souffre pas il lui en
faut plus pour s'offrir on continue
d'avancer avec cette image et on fait un
un panorama de tout ce qu'on a pu voir
depuis tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit
200000 pingouins sur man show c'est vrai
que si on a le réflexe de dire par 1 200
milles man show mais sur sur cette plage
des moments assez extraordinaire on
imagine que vous avez pu vivre je
voudrais qu'on continue et qu'on avance
ou est-ce qu'on est là ça c'est
mortadelle d'ailleurs ben j'en parlais
de stars c'est une des cabanes de
l'institut polaire et ce qui est
intéressant c'est le ba ya 20 ou 30 ans
le glacier qu'on voyait tout à l'heure
il arrivait à cette cabane et
aujourd'hui on le voit le glacier il est
bien là il est plus du tout ces photos
qui ont rythmé ces paysages qui ont
rythmé votre votre périple et donc vous
m'avez dit ils peuvent cohabiter ya pas
de problème on le voyait oui mais voilà
ils se partagent la plage ils se
partagent la plage alors qu'est ce que
c'est parce que vous êtes fait plaisir
sur ce marion dufresne bah ouais mais il
faut bien alors c'est ça c'est notre
repas de noël arpad bella lorsque vous
êtes parti dit man les dates 1er
décembre 31 décembre et là c'est noël à
bord du marion dufresne ça c'est un
privilège parce qu à amsterdam là on
tient donc là on est où là on est au
large d'amsterdam d'accord et à
amsterdam il ya des eaux tarik mais il
ya surtout et aussi des langoustes donc
celle là elles viennent d'être le mac le
matin même on peut pas avoir une
langouste plus fraîches au monde et on
fait aussi des barbecues j'ai bien
compris on fait la fête beaucoup
d'hommes de femmes comment ça serait
parti dans ses services maintenant
évidemment pendant très longtemps ça a
été très masculin les hivernages et les
opérations mais maintenant il ya ces on
n'est peut-être pas à la parité totale
mais où les femmes sont évidemment
présente est indispensable sur les
districts c'est la dernière photo là on
est de retour à la réunion retour au
port retour à la réunion
la différence de température là
j'imagine qu'on la sent ah bah ouais
c'est ça qui est assez magique quand on
remonte vers la réunion c'est qu'on sent
les vents chauds qui arrivent et en 24
heures tout change on passe d'un vent
froid un vent chaud on voit plus les
mêmes oiseaux et puis on revient voilà
et on n'a qu'une envie c'est de repartir
qu'est ce que vous retenez de ce périple
de ce reportage ci est allé une chose
vous dites j'ai appris ça m'a
impressionné je ne savais pas ça je
n'avais jamais vu ça je n'avais jamais
imaginé ça
trop difficile trop difficile et trop
dit fier c'est ce qu'il ya d'autres
endroits comme ça vous vous êtes isolé
dans tous vos reportages vous dites là
j'ai été aussi loin et est ce qu'on a
pas une peur peut-être un moment de se
blesser d'être loin de tout ah non non
non
en avoir peur faut profiter c'est quand
même c'est quand même génial de pouvoir
au 21ème siècle quand même aller dans
ces endroits où finalement peu de gens
sont allés à kerguelen ya 311 il ya des
îles qui ont jamais été foulé par
l'homme peut-être un jour soit c'est
quand même génial de se dire ça
aujourd'hui vous avez de la chance
vincent joly merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir bon j'espère vous avez pas trop
nui vous ne l'avez dit vous ça vous
plaisait pas les soirées photo vous êtes
port de maillots non moi je trouve que
on embête toujours les gens avec nos
photos de voyage non mais là ce ne sont
pas que des photos de voyages ce sont
aussi des photos de reportage vous
pouvez les retrouver ccc reportage
regardez ils sont ils sont ici les chats
évidemment plein d'histoires également
sur sur les éléphants de mer qui sont
devenus les alliés des scientifiques
c'est ce que vous nous expliquer tout à
l'heure et puis ce grand reportage avec
ses photos magnifiques merci beaucoup à
vincent joly merci qu'est ce que vous
avez à me proposer prochainement une
soirée photos j'ai pas mal j'ai une
expédition en antarctique de six
semaines en mer de vedel à bord à bord
du doubs plus grands voiliers
scientifiques au monde bombay rendez
vous bientôt on se fait ça très vite
merci merci de nous avoir suivis merci
beaucoup vincent joly grand reporter au
figaro magazine vous pouvez retrouver
tous ses papiers c'est passionnant c'est
très bien écrit même s'il trouve ça un
peu pompeux quand on sait que son père
lui que vous êtes très très bon et merci
à votre photographe on rappelle son
prénom et honda nissan est une
exposition on le rappelle aussi au
festival de la dsi merci beaucoup on se
retrouve très vite excellente soirée sur
figaro life